foreign
[Music]
first question is for you Edward you
know this project comes your way what
made you want to commit countless hours
of your life to making this film come to
life I mean it's a complete stupidity
right idiocy
um no uh it's it's it's I think it felt
immediately like a uh an immense
challenge uh something that a hurdle
that you can easily not jump over and
and and ruin it so it felt like a
challenge that I wanted to take but
mostly it's an opportunity that comes
along very rarely because it's it's not
a cheap movie and so the financing is
hard to get and
um and also it's a story that we can
rarely tell in Germany because in
America
there's a very different approach to
these types of films you know obviously
you have a very different history
America was roped into two Wars the
second one they liberated Europe from
fascism so there's a lot of uh in a way
there's this you know probably a sense
of honor and pride about those uh two
historical events whereas in Germany uh
there's you can't tell a story like that
and it's it's usually uh you know it's
it's it's you know there's just in in us
there's a sense of guilt or shame or
responsibility about history and that
informs the film so if you're an
American filmmaker or a British
filmmaker you make a film that has that
sense of pride in the film or and if
you're uh ideally I assume if you make a
German film it just feels very different
and I thought that that is a good
opportunity to share with the you know
other countries well um obviously yes
very true
obviously um we won't ask what the
actual budget is but I when we spoke a
couple weeks ago uh you had mentioned
that
people would be shocked that it is
nowhere near what you were able to
achieve on screen how did you pull that
off having such an epic scale on on what
you were provided with
I mean I I think in incredible
incredible amount of enthusiasm uh from
the team and uh and it's also I mean
budgets are just different in America to
Europe you know and and Eastern Europe
we shot this in Prague so uh and from
with the crew from all over the world uh
from England from Prague from uh France
from Germany and so a lot of good people
came together I think the title attracts
a great crew and and then I think a lot
of planning also just not wasteful uh
management of the resources so we we
basically spend I think I and the
cameraman spent three months locked in a
hotel room in Berlin and just
pre-planned every single shot and Drew
it and did storyboards and hung them
eventually on the wall like the entire
his entire hotel room and there was
covered it so there was no room service
or no food anywhere so we want to know I
usually came to the hotel room and
locked him in and then I went home and
then the next morning I came back and
brought him some food and then we
continued working and
um uh and so we spent a couple months in
this tiny hotel room and just sort of
really planned the movie and then hung
it up on the wall eventually the
pictures and edited the film on a wall
looking at the pigeon talking through it
and then realizing oh we're not going to
need that shot and this one we should
maybe make longer or slightly different
adapted so we drew it again and
eventually we sort of had the film on on
a wall and shot it exactly like we had I
mean not much difference
so I think that's also is helpful in
terms of
spending your resources that you have
well I want to ask these gentlemen some
questions as well but I just wanted a
quick follow-up on that you're on set
the weather's not what you want
um you know something breaks or whatever
you have stuck
everything to the storyboard how
stressful is that to just go every day
and and just try to attempt to pull off
what you have you know gone to the
the shots that that I mean to me it was
very stressful because the shots weren't
easy because usually they were very long
shots and you have actors and for the
human element you have actors you have
crew you have the weather and so things
go wrong you know like that you have a
gun in your hand it's a hundred years
old so jams you know you spent like two
three minutes the shot goes you think
everything's perfect and then in the
very end one of the you know one of the
actors like for example the opening
sequence it's a young actor maybe 19
years old or so and he has this gun and
then he tries to shoot and you know it
jams so you have to go again or the Sun
comes out and we didn't want Sun so
usually uh things went wrong 15 times
and on the 16th time it somehow worked
magically and somehow and for 15 times
you think like we're never ever gonna
get this shot it just doesn't work it's
too complicated and should be rethinking
this but somehow in the very end it you
know if you just keep with it in the
very end the shots usually worked out
Felix I want to ask you this is your
first uh on-screen role
um what was the audition process like I
mean also by the way absolutely
fantastic
[Applause]
what was the audition process like and
uh did you think you nailed it when when
you did your audition
well I um the story behind the audition
is quite funny because
um
I I started working in theater a few
years ago so I came from acting school
and started working at in Vienna State
Theater and um I worked with a drama
talk Sabrina and her husband Martin is
our producer
so um she worked with me and she said
maybe he's the one maybe you want to try
him and after a few weeks I got a phone
call by the casting director and we did
six months of casting
and I did I think three e-castings and
three or four live castings in Berlin
and in September October you sit in a
park with friends have a picnic and
suddenly you get a phone call and it's
Edward and he tells you we're going to
see us in Prague
and uh then you start celebrating
what about the the part excited you what
about playing Paul
um made you excited as an actor well
obviously it's it's this novel it's the
story that's that has been told in the
30s as a movie in the 70s as a movie and
um which is the the most printed German
novel
worldwide ever
um so of course that is intriguing but
at the same time it's
it felt to me like it was a time to tell
it
maybe something you would think too
um it was time to tell the story again
but from another generation
because since the 70s Generations have
just changed a lot and I think you can
each each version of the movie 30 79 and
now 2023 at 22.
is just
like a
representation of its generation it's it
shows how we deal with pictures of war
and
um coping with war so I'm very glad I
can't work on this new interpretation of
the story
well you're all fantastic Danielle
Daniel
I wanted to ask you
um uh you know you're playing one of the
few uh real historical figures uh in the
film did you feel like you needed to do
research uh to play him
oh yeah definitely yeah I was surprised
about how little I knew about this um
very fascinating man in German uh
history and and politics
um so I yeah I um read his biography
um and was uh very impressed
um very charismatic uh figure uh a
provincial politician from the south of
Germany who climbed up the ladder and
ended up in the high politics in Berlin
uh always you know with a
strong conviction values and morality
and he was targeted by the far right
very early on by for example opposing
against the colonial politics of the
German rice
but never got intimidated
um and I found it very appealing to open
up the film to have this layer which
gives us a very interesting historical
and political uh you know context to to
that story
um also I find it always very brave to
if you touch a holy material like All
Quiet on the Western Front to be bold
enough to to add something new if it's
you know
um in in the context of the story it is
accurate and it feels right because
cinematically speaking the structure at
the end is very interesting if you go
back and forth between the train
and the trenches and you might think oh
what a relief to be in that train on the
other hand you find it shocking you know
everything is so neat and Polished and
you have these few men who decide over
the fate of all these thousands of of
young soldiers so I I found this very um
appealing well I know you've recently um
put on a producing hat and started
producing projects what made you want to
be an executive producer on this as well
well I um the driving force behind this
project was clearly Malta kunat who's
here with us the the producer and so um
a big Applause
um so I I joined this wonderful man in
his company after having met him at a
film called The Most Wanted Man back in
the days and uh we quickly realized that
we share the same you know desires and
and and
um and taste we always wanted to find
interesting German material which has an
international appeal and so I remember
the conversation that we then one day
had when he called me and said listen I
found a great new adaptation of All
Quiet on the Western Front and it's in
English but we should do it in German
because it is it has never been done and
it was a real Epiphany I thought like oh
my God yes we we we have to do that and
um yeah and he put it together
um will Bullard I wanted to ask you
obviously you and Edward work together
on Patrick Melrose I'm assuming that's
how you guys knew each other yes uh what
about the project excited you
well it's uh first of all the story was
you know something that I like the book
I read as well when I was in school
and um I mean you know a film that is
dealing with the fate of young man being
thrown in something that is you know
with it that are going with an
enthusiasm into something that is
actually not you know a pro that is
promising in the first place but ending
very dramatically
um is something that I was I was very
attached to because I was the first I'm
the first generation or the first parent
that is having kids that have no parents
that went to war my parents went
experienced Civil War
um they were born in 1931 so in a way I
would say that is passed on you know me
on me and my generation in a way that uh
of course everything was you know we are
safe we were saving food and we were
like it was always a little bit like
um you know that things were
um the way they were passing on some
experiences from that time and so when I
saw when I read this the script again
and uh and I saw the film I think it I
actually
um saw the film first because it was
already nearly finished
um I had the feeling that this is very
inspiring because it has at the same
time it is very dramatic and it needs
some very violent elements in the music
I would say like very raw elements it
needs at the same time some poetic
elements to describe
I would say the length of life in a way
you know that is in their case very
short and that is dictated by people
that have already lived 70 years which I
think is very egoistic and um and they
were just uh and it's it's showing the
the absurdity of war in a big in a big
way and I thought to describe that with
music and finding an instrument
um like the harmonium that I used for
the for the main theme
um that is coming from that time I think
that was quite a challenge for me and I
loved that Edward was asking me
to join the project you know
well I know he's sitting right here but
do you remember what Edward said to you
was the most important thing to him
about what the score would sound like
yeah absolutely he said I want to have
something from you that I've never done
before
and I was like thank you
you know I went back home and it's
actually a little bit
that's what I love love about Edward and
I think you can sense that in the whole
group of people around the film
that there is no there is a very
positive encouragement
of going beyond what you've done before
which is uh I think every artist's dream
in a way that he can develop from where
he's standing right now
to go into the next
onto the next level and have somebody
who is actually pushing you gently into
that area rather than you know screaming
at you or like saying what is this you
know or yeah please do the the most the
thing that you've never done before and
then the next
week he says no I don't want to have
that you know and it's really
um I think when I send him the first
three notes this theme
when I send him that that was the day
after we watched
the movie the first time together and
that is a very when you when you feel
that is your
inspiration of the film and you've sent
it out it's a very raw
thing because when you get a feedback I
don't like it
and then you go home and you're very you
don't know what to do what you can do
next if there's anything else that you
can do
well my next question my next question
is for Edward and Felix you know
um many War films uh actors go through a
boot camp uh to sort of learn what their
character would know in a as a soldier I
I don't know if that was necessary here
but was that part of the process at all
or no
it's a great question for you to answer
but but also when just to add to folka
when he sent me that you know it's so
funny no no you just can't send a little
video like you've screened it on a movie
um on in the theater and we watch it
together and then the next day he sends
me his first idea in terms of the music
and you just get sent a little video and
you watch it on your computer but it
really blew me away because and I called
him up and said oh this this sounds like
Led Zeppelin you know and so and I I
kept calling it I kept calling it the
Led Zeppelin uh chords so can you do
more Led Zeppelin like on this other
part and so basically that's determined
the entire soundtrack those three notes
and the Led Zeppelin sound
but yeah boot camp that was the real
question
yeah we we had we had a kind of a boot
camp in the first it was the first week
during
um preparing in Prague
and we we as a as a team the actors
we were training with the stunt
department just to get used to military
movements and marching commands and
um
it was it was very helpful but I think
in the end what really was our boot camp
was our individual preparation
um for this movie because we all did
something completely different but in
the end we found out it's all led us to
the same point
um where we where we would work as as
comrades
basically so today I
um I learned something new from Felix
that I'd never heard before
and so a method that he developed in
terms of his uh in terms of knowing how
to act in each individual scene
I was really blown away that Edward
didn't know that well you kept it from
me well you didn't ask you but wait what
was it
I'm coming from theater I only know
working from A to B so in theater you
start performance and you end in the end
and then it's over so you're doing the
whole story but obviously when shooting
a movie you're not working
chronologically so for example the scene
where Paul is completely devastated in
the end we shot it on day four and since
I've never shot a movie before I thought
how am I going to do this
um because I don't know how
you know shooting the last scene on the
first day how is it going to work and
um I developed
maybe out of Despair I developed a
system
um that's basically an Excel spreadsheet
um because I I'm quite rational and
logic and I love numbers and I developed
a Nexus spreadsheet that uses multiple
categories for the character and each
category has multiple levels of energy
so um you have every scene linked to
multiple
categories and then again multiple
levels of energy and so you can see it
looks like a text
it's like a spreadsheet yeah like a
spreadsheet programming text stuff
and you can see the development of the
character and um
it looks very technical but to me it was
so helpful because it gave me something
to hold on and to rely on during the
shoot and I'm going to work like this
and with this spreadsheet for all the
shoots that are coming well that's
amazing I have to tell you that as a
journalist many times we see a film and
we see an actor in it we seem we think
that they've done this that they've like
tracked every single thing so that they
know but I was going to ask Daniel have
you ever done anything like this on a
role that you've done
my spreadsheet was breakfast lunch
dinner
I uh no it's like you know chronologic
you would write down in your uh script
on which day are you shooting what and
in which state are you uh uh in which
particular moments so of course you know
you're looking what happened before what
happened later but this is another level
you you should see it it's like uh this
this man is a is a mastermind
um well Edward I wanted to ask you you
know you talk about him doing one of his
toughest scenes like so early did you do
that on purpose in case you needed to go
back and do it again was it just do that
on purpose
just to just to torture you I knew no
um it's uh was it really day four
I think remember it you're right yeah
yeah in the very last scene it was day
four yeah yeah absolutely right I
remember I apologize now retroactively
uh no it's there's so many factors that
you know we don't have the money to
really schedule it consecutively on and
then the location is only available then
or you know it just doesn't fit
otherwise it's not definitely not on
purpose I'd rather shoot it
chronologically
but in the end uh you have to you know
you know make it in the most economical
way and I'm curious Felix did that give
you confidence getting through that
scene for the rest of the film
uh I think it was a I don't know what's
the word in English but it's uh like
baptized by fire
you know that works
um so it was the first shock on day four
uh okay that's that's the level we have
to reach and from that moment on I knew
what what was a mistake so it was really
quite easy from that point it was it was
really interesting because we did six
takes that day I remember exactly it's
when Felix and with the whole troop
walks up to this Ridge and looks over
the battlefield just before the final
battle
and you know the story is really about
the death of your soul in a way that uh
you're gonna have to
you know kill something inside of you to
survive or kill the other person so that
you can so it becomes you become a
survival Beast you kill everything else
in order so that you can hang on to life
but life is actually not worth anything
anymore because if you go home
you have no you know no connection to
your home anymore and to you what's
inside of it everything's dead inside so
he needed to be the character needed to
be dead inside at that point so we did
you know it was a complicated shot again
and a few times we screwed up with the
camera and Felix was always perfect of
course but we didn't capture it and um
and I remember
uh on the fifth take
he just burst into tears
and it I was completely devastated but
and and at the same time I knew it's not
really right for the scene because the
person
doesn't have tears anymore they've been
cried a long time ago
and so and then you've kind of
respectful and shy about it or at least
I am so I went up to him and didn't
quite know to put it actually Felix I
think maybe it's better
it's better I and and and uh and he just
said yeah no you know but he didn't he
couldn't he couldn't control it at that
point
and then the sixth take was just the
empty one then and that's the one that's
in the film
well um it's fantastic a great scene and
you you mentioned earlier
um an important thing about this film
that this story had not been in the
German language before it hadn't been
spoken and obviously it's been on
Netflix now for a couple of months I'm
just curious for for all of you what's
the reaction you've heard back home like
what do are people proud that this story
has come out this way does it matter to
them is it just any reaction you guys
have heard
um I'm I'm I personally am very grateful
for the reaction because
I get
uh a lot of emails from which I've never
gotten before for any other film uh
maybe you know once in a while your
agent gets an email that forwards you
from a colleague or something and but
this time I'm suddenly I don't know how
but like people out of the blue
sent me emails and I don't know where
they got my email or because it's never
anywhere and uh and just sort of
and from any country from many many
different countries
um
saying that they enjoyed the movie and
that it's a perspective that they're
interested in seeing so I'm very
grateful for that disruption and you
won't know what it means to us you know
we make
you know film sometimes they're smaller
sometimes they hit the audience and
sometimes the audience response
sometimes they don't you know and the
movie Just disappears and that this
movie now I mean this is the mecca of
movie making
and I'm from a pretty small town in
Germany and I never knew how to make
movies and it was never on the agenda of
becoming a director because I when I was
growing up I thought actors make movies
you know because they they speak the
lines so and they get filmed and you
think well they made up the lines and
then somehow I never thought about is
there a camera person is the director
and I just and when I found out there is
a director I thought oh that's I'm
really interested in that I want to make
that and so to now have a film in the
home of filmmaking that we can show to
you it's an incredible honor and it
really means a lot well yes it's
fantastic
um well gentlemen I want to thank you
all so much the movie is absolutely
superb and uh you should be so proud of
it and wishing you all the best uh over
this Awards season thank you so much
thank you very very much for coming
[Music]